i actually know um
a quote-unquote celebrity um not gonna
name names
and that celebrity was accused of grape
that celebrity was accused of grape once
and that celebrity
or that person
went to jail for a certain amount of
time for it
what that
person done after getting back out
is that they put camera recordings
or cameras sorry in their bedroom
and one day and he used to record he
would see women blah blah blah do you
know what i mean he see women
and
one day he had sex with a woman
and then and a couple days later she had
accused him of grape
again second time now
however the cameras
recorded the fact that he didn't do that
and he won his case
so
i know a lot of women
don't want to be recorded in their
intimate moments right
but the reason why i'm asking this
question is because of cases like this
cases like johnny
how would you feel as a woman
being recorded without your consent like
that
just as long as he's not
sharing it or showing it to anybody
go for it we'll make a movie you can
record me go for it
but
in that let me know
in that sense i don't
i think if it's for
like protection he should be able to
anybody should be able to record it just
in that case that it doesn't happen
again false allegations don't happen
again
like i said don't show anybody
yeah as long as it doesn't hit the
internet then it's fine because once it
hits the internet that woman can
technically now bring a case against you
for sharing pornographic images of her
about her without her consent and that's
a thing now
that's been a thing
you know before like early days of
internet people would get away with that
kind of thing now it's like yeah they
did because it's on the internet so
they'll tell you it's in an open space
but if the person didn't consent to it
yeah but you have to prove it right yeah
but you could you can watch it and you
know you've got again the professionals
yeah you can look and see if that person
would sorry you can see and if that
person was aware they were being
recorded yeah yeah you know and then
lines i think now it's been recorded but
i'm filming right now there's actually i
think there's laura around oh no
oh my god time to change so yeah maybe
there should be consent to record but
then there's consent to share if you say
you want to share it that's fine if you
say you don't want to share it and
that's your business no
i think there should be consent to share
it
but to record
i think if it's using like a court of
law and it hasn't been shared that
should be personally like i would never
want something recorded of me like out
there
you know like i just wouldn't want
someone to have the power to like
have that and i mean i always hear that
guys show like nudes to their friends
and stuff girls do the same thing
too okay okay but i'm not i'm not
talking about like i i'm sorry i'm not
into like that stuff so right um but i
just wouldn't want something like that
of me out there so if i
if i was like dating someone and i found
out he like took that without me knowing
i would have oh my god i'd be pissed no
i know i hate i understand i understand
why it's not like i don't understand why
i'm just saying
we are living it's like
my whole thing is like there's an adapt
or diet culture going on right now and a
lot of the people that don't adapt get
either eaten up or left behind in the
culture in which we live in an ideal
world no no one should record in anyone
we don't live in that world we live in a
world where people are going to go into
the trash and try and put a condom in
their
vagina and get hot sauce instead do you
know what i mean so it's like if we're
living in that we're living in a time a
woman can write a book saying how do you
destroy a man by leveraging alex this is
the times we're living in so it's like
people are going to have to adapt can i
ask a question an important question
about that book who published it
it's on amazon um is it self-published
or i i don't know who published it but
it's on amazon yeah i also was going to
add is that because it's quite
interesting about the whole recording
element as well because again in my
situation and it's what i mean about
protection and if it was the other way
around it would have been the case but
even when i brought forward to the judge
the recordings they had no issue they
didn't want to see it
i would have to pay 5 000. so the court
was basically saying to me to
to you know it's almost like strategize
let's go back to court in three months
if things change if things get better
then you know but that's why i was
interested in about this point about the
abuse because those scars that that
torment abuse violence and is it
coercive control
that just has to sit with me
and i'm good
but another man
not might have been even myself i do
question like how certain things why i'm
not in another place but
you know i think it's very important to
have these discussions
and that's why i said earlier
there
are cases and yours is a rare one when
you said that i was like whoa you had
evidence wow
where
mothers and women they can be
the worst of the worst but they'll still
have they'll still have their kids and
their father could be the right person
to take care of those kids and relieve
them of the situation that they're in
the mother literally has to be
the
bottom of the bottom of the bottom to
have her kids taken away she has to be
damn near very cool like abusing her
children for a man it's quick you do
something wrong boom your kids are taken
away from your visitation you gotta go
and see them in visitation and all this
stuff yeah and i think it should
automatically just be 50 50 custody yeah
like off the off the rep i don't i don't
think women automatically are better
parents just because they're women
that's a misconception yeah and that's
good sorry i think if men were giving
more chances to be parents in the sense
of the baby's born baby's breastfed
she's got to look after them she's got
to stay up at night or whatever it is
but i feel like because of the way
society is it doesn't encourage men to
be the night feeders it doesn't
encourage men to be the we don't have
breasts sorry um when i say night
feeders i mean in general like
my kid wasn't breastfed the whole time
he had bottles so really and truthfully
if he was encouraged to pick up that
bottle and say do you know what you
sleep i'm gonna feed him i'm gonna spend
it who's working who's going to work
so if he does that
is he going to work in the morning
to bring home to bring home to provide
for the house
only to be breastfeeding when you're
supposed to be sleeping because it's got
work the next day saying about there has
to be the balance in it yeah but that's
what i'm saying balance i'm not saying
it has to be all the time but if there
was more if there was more encouragement
for men to be
more
paternal
i wouldn't say maternal but let's just
say if they if they if it was more
encouraged and not looked down on
because when you see a man that's a stay
at home dad people are like men are men
are better single parents than mothers
on average
like that
but it's factual with statistics no i
mean i would agree i know some crazy
moms like i know i know okay all the
parents like i don't know to be honest
most of my friends growing up like
their parents stayed together but the
ones that i know that got divorced oh my
god i would i would 100 pick their dad
every single time because their mom was
freaking nuts